ومشاهدينا في تداعيات محاكمه ترامب ايضا
ما هي سيناريوهات المحتمله السياسيا طبعا
بعد توجيه هذا الاتهام سيكون ترامب والذي
يبلغ من العمر 76 عاما في ورطه كاول رئيس
سابق او في المنصب يوجه اليه الاتهام
بارتكاب جنايه ومع عدم معرفه التهم
بالتحديد الموجهه لترامب من الصعب طبعا
التكهن ان كانت الادانه المحتمله ستؤدي
الى الحكم بالسجن على رئيس امريكي السابق
مع ذلك يعتقد بان التهم التي ستوجه الى
ترامبس تشمل الاحتيال التجاري ستشمل
انتهاكات متعلقه بتمويل الحملات
الانتخابيه ولكن من غير الواضح ان كانت من
جرائم الجنايات والتي طبعا تؤدي الى عقوبه
السجن المحتمله توقيت الازمه هو الاسواق
طبعا ياتي ايضا على اعتاب انتخابات يامل
ترامب في من خلالها الى العوده الى البيت
الابيض سيواصل ترامب بالتاكيد مسعاه لخوض
الانتخابات حتى في حال مواجهته تهاما
جنائيه فلا يوجد اي بند في الدستور
الامريكي يمنعه من الترشح للرئاسه حتى في
حال مواجهته التهم